all right serious question would you
rather [__] Sam an the fox in her prime
but she's wearing a Barbara Bush mask or
[__] Barbara Bush but you get to have
Samantha just looking at you full eye
contact and she's naked oh wow that's a
good one thank you I you always got the
left turn mm I mean I think I got to go
with the combo platter I mean Samantha
Fox is smoking hot but if I get both of
them you know I get to look at Samantha
and you know Pap Bush I think she was a
clean woman you know yeah and I never
been that close to that level of power
before do it the Oval Office I you know
pick up the red phone see who's on the
other side the oval
orifice yeah dude bunch of guys right
trashing women yeah so cool you guys are
so dope what are we offending you no man
you're not offending me no I just think
this misogynistic Behavior amongst
groups of men is a little uh little
cliche ah Jesus Christ we got a feminist
in the car